Stand up straight and look me in the eye,
new recruits!
Now you listen up and you listen good, if
you’re watching this then that means you’ve
been selected to join the dedicated staff
of the SCP Foundation.
Tell me, soldier, do you intend to give your
life in the service of the cause, and strive
to secure anomalies of all kinds, contain
those anomalies, and protect the innocent
general public from their influence or knowledge?
That’s what I like to hear!
Here at the Foundation, we have collected
some of the deadliest, most sophisticated,
and strangest weaponry the world has ever
seen.
Forget everything you think you know about
combat, because I’m taking all of you back
to school.
Sharpen your pencils and get ready to take
some detailed notes, because I’ll be taking
you into the Foundation Armory for a first-hand
look at some of the most powerful and anomalous
weaponry we have come across in our years
of operation.
We try to avoid using any of these specimens
for combat purposes, but in this line of work,
you never know when you might need to be ready
to head into battle against any government,
an alien species, or evil itself.
So our motto is, what?
Always be prepared for the worst!
Besides, one of these little peashooters might
wind up being the key to eventually neutralizing
SCP-682.
Infernal lizard.
Ahem.
Anyway, let’s get down to business.
Let’s start with the big guns.
Meet SCP-044, secretly manufactured by German
engineers toward the during the Second World
War.
044 is a howitzer, a large ranged weapon similar
to a cannon.
If you’re intimidated by its size, you should
be.
It’s 251 metric tons of artillery power,
and its unusual qualities keep going.
Unlike other howitzers, which use a breech
for loading shells, 044 uses a giant air-compression
chamber.
Any object that can fit into the weapon’s
muzzle can be used as ammunition.
Once an object has been loaded in, the howitzer
somehow weakens its molecular and atomic bonds,
transforming it for ideal impact.
Once the weapon is fired, the matter in the
barrel is shot out at high speed in the form
of a glowing red slug - slug as in projectile,
not the animal.
Get it together, recruit - equal to the mass
of the original object loaded into the barrel.
The largest slug produced so far was 19,500
pounds, the result of loading The Administrator’s
pickup truck into the muzzle of SCP-044.
Up next, a weapon that packs a real bite.
I don’t normally stoop to puns, but a sense
of humor is required to keep up morale around
here, so yes.
That was a play on words.
Don’t get used to it.
SCP-127 appears to be an ordinary MP5K-PDW
submachine gun, with one notable exception:
it’s alive.
Aside from its outer shell of steel and polymer,
tests have indicated that it is made of living,
organic material.
When fired, the gun does not expel bullets,
but teeth.
They look like human teeth, but DNA tests
found no match for any species on Earth.
127 features semi-automatic and fully automatic
settings, and produces an audible groaning
sound when it switches between the two.
So far, it doesn’t seem to be deadlier than
an ordinary weapon of the same type, but never
underestimate the importance of psychological
warfare or what it might do to an enemy soldier’s
thought process when he sees teeth flying
at him at lightning speed.
Up next we have, not a gun, but a blade.
SCP-034 is a knife carved from pure obsidian,
with an estimated age of approximately 1000
years old.
In all that time, it has not lost its edge,
and remains just as sharp as if it were freshly
made.
But that’s not all: whoever wields this
knife is able to take on the appearance of
another person, as long as they have cut a
piece of their intended target’s skin off
with the knife.
It’s the ultimate tool for espionage.
This next weapon may look like a toy, but
if you spend enough time at the Foundation
you’ll quickly learn that nothing is exactly
as it seems.
SCP-3108 shares the appearance of a Nerf brand
dart gun, but this piece of machinery does
a lot more than shoot simple foam darts.
Created by Nathan Pierce, this gun has the
ability to turn anything it hits into a worse
version of itself.
A dollar turns into a quarter, a piece of
printer paper becomes one-ply toilet paper,
and - now here’s where its combat applications
come in - a human man turns into a neanderthal.
Hit a man enough times with this Nerfing gun,
and he’ll degrade further and further each
time until he’s essentially just a tiny
earthworm you can crush beneath your boot.
It’s nothing to play around with.
Speaking of highly destructive weaponry that
looks like a toy, SCP-1068 is a collection
of model rockets, measuring at about a meter
in length apiece.
On the back of their packaging, a note is
written: “Harness the Raw-ket power of Dr.
Wondertainment's new line of model rockets
with The Atom Buster®!
This pint-sized monster launches a thousand
feet in the air before plummeting to a climactic
explosion of nuclear proportions.
Truman would be proud.
Utilizing a state-of-the-art light and sound
system, the greatest weapon ever detonated
can be used again… on your front lawn!
You can even customize your model with the
accompanying realistic decal sheet to make
its launch a more awesome one.”
Though these pint-size rockets don’t pack
the punch of a real nuclear missile, they’re
more than capable of causing permanent damage
to the eyes and ears of anyone in the vicinity
when they’re detonated, as well as knocking
out all electronic communications in the area
for up to 20 hours.
For a harmless-looking explosive that can
render an opponent blinded, deafened, and
unable to cry for help, these will do the
job just fine.
Have you ever heard of the Bystander Effect?
It’s the concept that, when faced with a
horrific event, many people instinctively
will do nothing to stop it.
Instead, they will simply stand by.
SCP-668 weaponizes the Bystander Effect, and
guarantees it no matter what atrocities you
commit.
It is a 13-inch chef’s knife with a rosewood
handle that, when held by a human being intending
to commit violence against another, gives
off a psychic signal that renders all nearby
sentient beings unable to intervene.
Its effects have been reported as feeling
like an overwhelming sense of apathy.
Additionally, it renders the victim of the
attack unable to defend themselves.
There’s really no limit to the amount of
violence SCP-668’s holder could get away
with…but don’t get any ideas, this knife
is under high-level containment.
Sometimes a weapon isn’t a blade, or a gun.
Sometimes it’s a simple piece of plate glass,
like SCP-3154.
I say simple, but you know the drill by now.
It’s a bit more complicated than it looks.
SCP-3154 is a triangular piece of glass, 16.2
cm long and 8 cm wide.
When used to attack a person, the glass puts
them into an unusual state, referred to in
the official file as a Sigma State.
And if I hear you making any “Sigma Male”
jokes during this presentation, mark my words,
I will snap your pencil-necks like stale breadsticks.
A Sigma State is characterized by the following:
Absence of breathing and heartbeat, blood
settling in the lower parts of the body and
causing noticeable discoloration, gradual
reduction of body temperature, stiffness,
and a dramatically decreased immune system.
If a person is left in a Sigma State for too
long, worms, flies, and other environmental
organisms will begin to feed on their body.
Now, you might be wondering what’s so special
about this?
A Sigma State sounds like it’s just regular
old death.
And you’re right, it is.
This glass isn’t special because it kills
people, it’s special because it somehow
prevents anyone from recognizing its victims
as dead.
Depending on who sees you use this piece of
glass to attack someone, you could quite literally
get away with murder.
Up next is SCP-5175, a detailed knife with
a Moroccan style of design and an uncertain
origin.
When handled by most people, this is nothing
more than a regular, if ornate, blade.
However, when handled by the right person
- currently an individual known as PoI-3445
- the knife is able to remove any life form
from reality entirely.
It doesn’t just kill them, it eradicates
them.
Once the knife, in the hand of its designated
holder, has pierced a target, black mist begins
to pour from the target’s wound.
It wraps around the target, and they disappear
completely, teleported out of our reality
and into an extradimensional space known as
“The Land of the Forsaken Suffering.”
The one who wields the knife is also accompanied
by the spirit of a Japanese samurai named
Kuroitanken Hanzo, a great warrior from the
1800s.
It’s not just a knife capable of removing
its targets from this world, but it comes
with the experience of a long-dead veteran
fighter.
SCP-958 also has a great deal of military
expertise to offer.
It is a toy robot, made of plastic and tin,
standing at nineteen centimeters tall.
On the bottom of the robot’s right foot,
there is text printed that reads: “General-Beep,
by Dr. Wondertainment.”
General-Beep is activated by flipping a switch
on the back of its head, at which point it
is able to speak and move on its own.
When it is introduced to a child under the
age of 13, General-Beep will teach them about
military history, and will eventually teach
the child how to build copies of the toy robot,
as well as weapons including guns that shoot
paint, cannons that fire plush toys at high
speeds, and guns that shoot beams of focused
light hot enough to melt steel.
It may be a toy, but this General is not playing
around.
Up next, we have a set of anomalous hand grenades,
SCP-5969.
These grenades are stored inside a World War
II-era wooden crate, and do not present any
unusual properties until they are exposed
to water in a liquid state, or to particularly
humid air.
Once they have been exposed to enough moisture,
the grenades will instantly detonate, whether
the pin and spoon have been removed or not.
While normal grenades expel metal shrapnel
on explosion, instances of SCP-5969 propel
seeds that sprout into flowering plants as
soon as they hit a solid surface.
If these plants make contact with the skin
of a living person, they will begin to suck
out the person’s blood at a speed of 15
mL/second.
This will continue until the host has bled
to death.
Really gives a new meaning to War of the Roses.
SCP-5871 is not used for physical warfare,
but rather for metaphysical types of combat.
It is an obsidian ritual knife with a gem-encrusted
handle.
When the knife is used to symbolically kill
an entity via a specific, classified ritual,
it destroys that entity retroactively.
This knife has been used to take care of multiple
dangerous intangible anomalies since its creation,
and it is ready to be used again if the need
arises.
Here we have SCP-4282, also known as Mutiny’s
Bane.
If you’re thinking it looks like something
right out of a pirate ship, you’re right.
It is a .44 caliber single shot black powder
handgun, and it operates exactly like any
other gun of its kind.
However, the bullet that leaves the gun does
not exit the barrel in a straight line.
Instead, it has a target in mind as soon as
it’s been loaded, regardless of which way
the gun’s holder aims it.
Once it is fired, SCP-4282 delivers a deadly
gunshot wound to the back of the head of the
nearest living human being guilty of piracy
or stealing a nautical ship.
The wound is identical every time: the bullet
enters through the parietal bone and exits
through the right eye socket.
This gun only comes in handy once in a blue
moon these days, since piracy has been on
the decline for the past couple centuries
or so, but you never know when you’ll come
across the old skull and crossbones.
You can never be too prepared.
Nikola Tesla was responsible for some of the
greatest technological advances in history,
including the tesla coil and the remote control.
If only he invented a way to keep me from
losing that damn thing, but I digress.
Oh No!
What did I do!
One of his lesser-known inventions is SCP-2700,
which he created with the intention of producing
a directed-energy weapon.
It is comprised of three parts, which, when
combined, would produce a chain reaction that
could destroy the universe as we know it.
To explain it in layman’s terms, it would
create the opposite of the Big Bang.
That’s one that we’d better keep under
wraps.
Probably forever, if we can help it.
Up next, we have SCP-2818, an array of sixteen
firearms that look identical to Barrett M82A1
anti-materiel rifles , with one difference:
the words “H&W Mod #9” are printed on
the guns where the Barrett identification
would normally be.
These firearms load like a standard Barrett
M82A1, but if someone pulls the trigger, they
will immediately disappear.
A round will then be fired from the barrel
of the gun, but it is not the one loaded into
the gun’s chamber.
Instead, it is comprised of the organic matter
making up the person who pulled the trigger,
converted into the shape of a .50 BMG round.
These rounds match up with the estimated weight
and density of a human being that has been
compressed into that size and shape.
It converts the soldier into the ammunition.
Talk about human resources.
SCP-186 was discovered in 1917, and is the
location of an unrecorded military conflict
between the Imperial German Army and the Russian
Provisional government.
From this area, the SCP Foundation recovered
and contained a collection of unusual weaponry,
which are now kept in a Foundation facility.
First, a modified version of the Skoda M1909
machine gun, which causes rapid tumorous growths
within the body of any organism larger than
a lab rat.
There were mortar shells that contained a
gas that caused animal cells to be unable
to die.
A coil of Concertina wire was discovered,
covered in an unidentifiable hallucinogenic
substance with permanent effects on the human
brain.
Eventually, they discovered grenades filled
with a gas that is able to penetrate any gas
mask and cause the feeling of being lit on
fire, and a number of French rifle cartridges
filled with powdered human bone.
We’ve talked about weapons that shoot and
stab, but we haven’t yet covered one of
the most powerful tools of warfare: the tank.
That brings us to SCP-802, which resembles
a World War II era Renault Char B1 medium
battle tank.
Unlike other tanks from this era, which need
to be operated by a soldier inside, this tank
operates entirely on its own.
There is no one inside running its controls,
but it still continues to operate independently.
It has undergone severe physical damage, but
it still is plenty capable of keeping up in
a fight.
It achieves a speed of up to 40 kilometers
per hour, and can take hits from anti-tank
weapons without faltering.
It has caused over 47 casualties since being
contained, so whatever cosmetic damage it’s
sustained doesn’t seem to have hurt it too
much.
Strangest of all, music plays from inside
the tank’s hull, with no apparent source.
Usually, this music is from the late nineteenth
and early twentieth centuries.
Though its purpose is uncertain, some researchers
believe it to be a form of psychological warfare
intended to unsettle the tank’s perceived
enemies.
SCP-705 is kept in this 5 oz container of
Play-Doh, which keeps it dormant and harmless.
If you open this container, however, the squishy
red substance inside begins to move.
Hundreds of tiny humanoid shapes pour out
of the clay, turning into miniature army men.
These aren’t your usual army man toys, though.
They’re outfitted with completely functional
automatic weapons.
They’re also highly aggressive and territorial,
choosing locations to invade and working together
to take them over.
They’re sentient, understand English, and
operate within a militaristic hierarchy.
Most impressive, and troubling, of all however,
is their ability to multiply.
Get your mind out of the gutter, recruit!
If the tiny soldiers encounter another container
of Play-Doh, or a similar model clay, it will
also spring to life and become a new army
of tiny soldiers.
Once the army’s out of the can, they will
remain active until they’ve been stuffed
back inside.
You’ve probably heard of the guillotines
used to execute the powerful during the French
Revolution.
SCP-374 is one of these guillotines, constructed
from an oak frame and a sharp steel blade.
When used to execute a human being, something
bizarre happens.
The head of the victim becomes overtaken by
the personality of a man from the French Revolution
named Jean-Philippe-Horace-Donatien for a
duration of 35 minutes.
It is able to answer questions during this
time, though it tends to be uncooperative
due to its mistrust of the Foundation.
Which, considering it becomes conscious only
after a head is chopped off a human body,
makes some sense.
Then we have another pistol, but one that
is like nothing else we’ve seen today.
SCP-1998 is a pistol of unknown make and model.
The peculiar thing about 1998 is its lack
of any ammunition.
Rather than firing any kind of bullets, the
gun fires a pulse of energy from an undetermined
power source.
These pulses of energy have no effect on a
target that is not a human body.
If it hits a human, however, it has a notable
effect on the brain, particularly the motor
cortex, the primary auditory cortex, and the
hippocampus.
Once someone has been hit, three things happen.
First, the target turns and sits down in front
of the person wielding SCP-1998.
Then, the target becomes paralyzed and has
no control over their physical movement.
The target will then listen to, and believe,
anything that the person firing SCP-1998 says
to them.
The operator of the weapon is then able to
rewrite their victim’s memories and give
them commands, which the victim will follow
as closely as possible as soon as they can
move again.
Victims of SCP-1998 have described the effects
of the weapon as horrifically painful and
traumatic, and that comes as no surprise.
It is, essentially, a weapon that allows its
user to fight against free will itself.
Now get to work!
And remember, as you walk past the containment
cells, keep your eyes to yourself.
You might see something you don’t want to
see…or something that really, really doesn’t
want you to see it.
Now go check out “SCP-3108 The Nerfing Gun”
and “SCP Elite Mobile Task Force Explained”
for more combat and weaponry at the SCP Foundation.